[Musique]
merci merci je me présente
hakim benaja je suis est lé 23e et ce
soir j'ai une question pour vous avez
vous déjà rêvé ou imaginer l'espace de
demain et ben moi ça a vraiment commencé
en octobre 2015 voulu devenir designer
automobile et je suis allé au cinéma
voir seul sur mars et en sortant du
cinéma 60 la salle je voulais partir
dans l'espace explorer mars et ses
secrets
à partir de là j'ai commencé à rêver de
plein de trucs un petit peu comme les
anciens d'explorateurs en fait et après
je me suis mis à regarder plein de
vidéos youtube je regarder des films des
livres et voilà je me suis aussi un
petit peu penché sur le parcours à
suivre pour devenir dix ingénieurs
aérospatiale parce que le fait de
développer des vaisseaux c'est
l'ingénierie spatiale ont maintenant mes
recherches j'ai découvert que
il y avait plein de contraintes qu'il
fallait gérer pour atteindre nos
objectifs a alors tout d'abord pas des
moindres il ya la gravité alors comme
vous le savez peut-être tueur être sur
terre il ya une force qui nous retient
au sol qui s'appelle la gravité et qui
nous empêche de fautes et partout et
dans l'espace
y'a pas de gravité en flotte partout et
c'est pas rigolo de flotter
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
on flotte et en fait quand on flotte
dans l'espace on vit de façon accélérée
en fait on perd de la masse musculaire
on perd de la masse osseuse et on vit
arte est réellement il ya aussi les
radiations alors ça les radiations
c'est encore pire ça entraîne des
tumeurs des mutations des maladies
chelou franchement c'est pas sympa et
devinez quoi
plus les temps de trajets sont longs et
ben plus les dents les dangers que j'ai
juste évoqué juste avant sont accrues et
ben ils sont justement il faut en fait
six mois pour partir sur mars est à peu
près un peu plus d'un an pour y revenir
mais c'est pas encore tout comme vous le
savez pour vivre enfin nous quand on vit
on à l'électricité on a de la lumière on
fait chauffer nos aliments et dans
l'espace il faut aussi de l'électricité
et il faut aussi de l'électricité pour
respirer aussi pour recycler l'air est
alors la solution la plus fréquemment
utilisés à l'heure actuelle c'est les
panneaux solaires et les panneaux
solaires ça marche ça fonctionne mais
nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est allé
très très loin dans l'espace parce qu'on
est des rêves
et plus tu vas loin dans l'espace en
fait moins les moyens de soleil en fait
tout simplement et donc moyen
d'électricité ensuite c'est aussi le
problème de la nourriture et de
l'oxygène
non vous savez peut-être il ya des
astronautes qui tourne en orbite autour
de notre
des routes une au dos au dessus de nos
têtes et eux ils sont alimentés par la
tv le cargo ravitailleur européen le
véhicule automatique de transfert
européen
pardon assez souvent qui leur apporte
nourriture et oxygène frais mais à 70
millions de kilomètres sur mars
on n'a pas d'à tv c'est le problème est
là vous allez vous dire peut-être que ça
m'a freiné dans mon rêve voilà tous ces
contraintes 7 a freiné mais en fait pas
du tout vous l'aurez peut-être deviné je
suis de cela ici aujourd'hui
en fait pas du tout et ça m'encourage à
encore plus trouver des solutions pour
qu'on puisse partir dans l'espace et je
fabrique un petit peu ses solutions dans
ma tête
grâce à l'imagination et donc je vous
invite à me suivre dans mon rêve du de
la ville futuriste de la vie dans
l'espace
tout d'abord pour partir dans l'espace
on a besoin de vaisseaux et les petits
vaisseaux on a des petits vaisseaux
d'avoir ça c'est plutôt pour des
équipages restreint plutôt d'exploration
etc ensuite on a les plus gros vaisseaux
même beaucoup plus gros qui sont eux
plutôt orienté vers le voyage commercial
touristes mais pas que il ya aussi du
fret pour alimenter les différentes
colonies et des astronautes qui voyage
grâce à ça alors là vous allez me dire
mais alors toutes les contraintes nous a
dit avant comment les ont fait face à ça
dans nos vaisseaux et ben on va créer
des technologies je l'espère en tout cas
et tu sais que tu es logis sont les
suivantes pour pour faire face à la
hollande de gravité simplement utilisé
une force toute bête la force centrifuge
en fait je passe voir il ya des grands
auront des sortes deux roues est en fait
à vitesse constante cela produit une
force
il s'appelle la force centrifuge et qui
pousse vers l'extérieur et donc qui va
venir reproduire simplement la gravité
terrestre
ensuite pour les contraintes de
rayonnement et bien là on va utiliser
tout simplement on va reproduire un
petit peu chez passion sur terre en fête
pour faire face aux rayonnements on a
notre atmosphère on a des rayons
magnétique autour de la terre qui
empêche qu'on reçoive dans la figure
tout ce qui est rayons gamma rayons x
l'état et sur nos vaisseaux on va
reproduire un petit peu la même chose
mais artificiellement en générant des
champs magnétiques qui pourront arrêter
ses rayons gamma énervant vous allez me
dire mais est un trajet ils sont
vraiment long et comment on va faire
j'ai envie de rester six mois dans
l'espace
et ben ouais alors moi non plus alors
pour ça on va utiliser tout simplement
des systèmes de propulsion avancé on a
dit à différents types on à la fusion
nucléaire à ne pas confondre avec la
fission nucléaire
on a aussi les voiles solaires comme ça
qui en fait avec une force la pression
de radiation qui pousse le véhicule à
des vitesses folles en fait de manière
progressive
bon et malheureusement comme
l'électricité c'est pareil plus tu
t'éloignes du soleil - un tas de soleil
et donc moins tu vas vite et on a aussi
la propulsion ionique qui accélère des
lions à très haute vitesse
alors ces vaisseaux il partirait d'une
station spatiale alors ça serait une
sorte de port spatial où transiteraient
astronautes touristes et fret donnant un
accès à l'espace via les vaisseaux que
j'ai cité juste avant
alors la lune quant à elle elle serait
une sorte de base arrière une base
scientifique ont développé et fabriqué
des vaisseaux et les habitats pour
pouvoir partir ailleurs dans l'espace
sur mare et ça ça serait un peu notre
usine quoi et la lune c'est aussi cool
parce qu'il n'ya pas d'autres mots ce
faire et que l'atmosphère c'est un frein
à l'observation du cosmos parce que
s'accéler des sorts d'annulation et
depuis la terre on n'arrive pas à bien
voir le cosmos profond et pour remédier
à ça on a créé les télescopes spatiaux
donc on en voit on dépense des milliards
envoyés des télescopes spatiaux en
orbite et bien la solution c'est tout
simplement qu'on fabrique raynaud
télescopes sur la lune et qu'on les
installerait directement sur la lune et
comme ça on peut observer les oiseaux de
la lune c'est très intéressant aussi
parce que rares sol lapierre lunaire
s'appelle larigot lite elle regorge
d'hélium 3 or c'est un guillaume iii la
fusion de l'hélium 3 est beaucoup plus
efficace que la fission nucléaire est
totalement propre et je vous ai dit que
la lune serait aussi une base arrière
mais une base à quoi une base arrière à
le haut une porte ouverte au reste de 2
du système solaire donc je parle bien
sûr de mars et d'au-delà donc parlant de
mars marseille planète alors mars c'est
pas très accueillant mais dans 50 ans
ben mars c'est cool
voilà marc c'est cool on part en voyage
sur mars voilà on fait ses valises en
mars grâce notamment à des dogmes des
dom du grand dôme
qui pourront accueillir des chants des
laboratoires des maisons habitat pour
qu'on puisse se vivre entièrement en
autosuffisance en se produisant de
l'énergie localement comme par exemple
avec la fusion de l'hélium 3 et tout est
recyclé bien entendu et cette
microsociété martienne bien sûr on peut
pas imaginer qu'elle pourrait reposer
sur de l'argent pas possible donc pas
d'argent et tout est axé sur le partage
et les collectivisations alors autour de
mars y aurait un de ses porte patio
encore pourquoi parce que marc ce serait
aussi une base arrière encore une base
arrière cette fois ci à l'exploration et
l'exploitation de la ceinture
d'astéroïdes
en fait la ceinture d'astéroïdes il ya
quoi dans la ceinture d'astéroïdes maria
des astéroïdes et dans les astéroïdes
il ya plein de matériaux des matériaux
normaux un petit meuble comme le métal
et le plomb quoi et on a aussi des
matières premières plus plus rares comme
l'or le platine le diamant aussi encore
plus rare et tout ça en les extrayant
grâce à des mines spatiale des mines sur
les astéroïdes
on peut les extraire et les revendre sur
terre les transformé par exemple sur la
lune et le revendre sur terre pour
rentabiliser nos voyages parce que
l'espace ça coûterait très cher
je voudrais maintenant par les doux delà
de la ceinture d'astéroïdes encore là là
où se trouvent saturn et c'est l'une les
lunes
elles sont très intéressante parce que
on peut se poser dessus c'est aussi et
surtout d'un point de vue scientifique
elles sont très intéressantes comme par
exemple titan la petite boule marrant
alors à l'ensemble beaucoup à la terre
parce que là l'anatomie je sais pas si
on pourrait dire comme ça de la terre
des continents des océans sauf que l'eau
des océans et ben ça serait tout
simplement du méthane liquide
enfin c'est du méthane qui est le métal
liquide c'est quoi c'est le signe ici à
l'heure actuelle une sorte de carburant
ça c'est un carburant de fusées et de
différents on peut utiliser ça comme des
carburants on peut l'exploiter pour en
prendre le méthane quoi et alimenter des
sondés des drones qui pourraient voyager
sur titan et l'explorer en fait
l'autre cible très intéressante de
saturne enfin des lunes de saturne c'est
en cela ben alors la petite planète
bleue et blanche
alors pourquoi une bleue et blanche
parce qu'en fait elle est faite de glace
tous avant tout sa croûte et de glace
est en fait sous sa croûte de glace donc
la glace ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
de l'eau et sous sa croûte de glace
il y aurait en fait des océans d'après
les centres qu'on a envoyé des océan
d'eau sale et liquides donc c'est de la
vie et c'est très intéressant mais là
vous me direz un petit peu donc là j'ai
fini un petit peu mon voyage avec
l'imaginaire jeu parce que vous aurez
fait voyager et là vous devez sûrement
vous dire mais à quoi ça sert à hakim à
quoi ça sert de rêver quand on est un
scientifique et ben
cette question est très importante parce
qu'à mon sens un scientifique c'est quoi
c'est quelqu'un qui va imaginer le futur
ici projette en menant des recherches en
concevant en recommençant pour que par
exemple demain vous et moi puissions
être guéri du cancer en fait
l'imagination ça occupe une place
centrale vraiment dans tous les domaines
scientifique et du monde en général
parce que si on n'imagine pas on peut
pas appréhender le futur on peut pas
découvrir de nouvelles choses parce
qu'un petit peu toute invention par un
petit peu de l'imaginaire de son
inventeur donc c'est très important et
donc parlons d'imagination et rajoutons
l'espace maintenant et là on est aux
anges
parce que vous devez sûrement le
connaître un petit peu l'espace star
wars star trek celle sur mars
c'est un sujet extrêmement exploité dans
la liste du rallye littérature et la
cinématographie là j'ai un autre message
aussi à vous faire passer aujourd'hui
puisque vous êtes beaucoup de jeunes je
pense que moi par exemple si je devais
rêver toute la journée
je sais bien de rêver mais ici je rêve
toute la journée toute l'année est resté
sur le canapé à rien faire je pourrai
jamais concrétiser mon rêve donc c'est
vraiment la première étape de la
concrétisation crétinisation son rêve
rêver et puis après passer à l'action
d'ailleurs j'aime beaucoup la citation
suivante il ya ceux qui se recouche pour
continuer le rêve et d'autres qui se
lève pour le réaliser je pense que voilà
il faut vraiment faire à son échelle je
suis si on a vraiment un rêve si on a
vraiment envie de faire quelque chose si
on se donne les moyens
tout est possible et même aussi petite
soit elle c'est très important
j'aimerais faire une sorte de petit
ballon météorologique que je pourrais
envoyer dans l'atmosphère les couches
supérieures de l'atmosphère pour un
petit peu relevé des informations
prendre des images pourquoi pas de la
terre
et là vous allez me dire mais si tous
minuscule tu nous a dit des choses
extraordinaires l'exploration spatiale
c'est énorme mais c'est ça c'est tout
minuscule le ballon et ben je pense que
c'est déjà à mon sens le sens de mon
rêve quelque chose de super important
c'est déjà un une action et comme je
vous ai dit aussi petite soit elle
c'est très important parce que c'est
déjà un pas dans le futur
c'est le début de la concrétisation de
votre rêve et donc voilà je pense que
c'est comme ça que le monde avance en
imaginant l'imagination comme un super
moteur ayew qui va super vite et je
pense que c'est aussi ça qui nous
différencie des autres animaux notre
capacité à imaginer
et pour finir une question encore une
question vous pour votre futur qu'est ce
que vous imaginiez merci
[Musique]